so the the gentleman and the blue
sweater at the back can you hear me
thank you
foreign
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
welcome to this extraordinary meeting of
stratford-on-avon District council's
cabinet my name is Darren Pemberton I'm
the deputy leader of the district
council I'm sitting in to chair this
meeting today
um in the place of the leader of the
council who is unfortunately unwell
um for the benefits of the worldwide
public audience out there
um I've just advised uh members of
cabinet and members of the public in the
room that we are going to change the
running order for today's meeting we're
going to move item number seven land at
Knights Lane tiddington
um to be heard as the item the first
substantive item of the meeting
immediately after uh apologies for
absence disclosures of interest and
minutes that will enable the the
audience in the room to hear the item
that they're interested in
and then to be able to uh to get on with
their real lives
um this is also somewhat of an
experiment
um in that we have a brand new AV system
in place so apologies in advance as we
all get it wrong uh certainly uh I mean
I'm in that category where the only
reason for having a 20-something son is
to program the sky box so with this
thing I'm absolutely doomed and
with out any more a Jew let's move on
with the meeting uh do we have any
apologies of absence for absence
we do we have apologies from councilor
Jefferson as you've already mentioned
and councilor cargill's joining us
online
thank you very much
disclosures of Interest members of
cabinet members are reminded to display
declare the existence of uh disclosable
pecuniar interests other registerable
interests or non-registerable interests
in so doing to explain the nature of the
interest and the connection between that
interest and the agenda item and to
State what action if any they intend to
take such as not participating in the
meeting does any member have any
specific
interest to advise for today
take that as a no third item is to
confirm and sign the minutes of the
meeting held on the 28th of November
and I do see true to form councilor
Javier a residence grammatical Guru
has some observation to make on the
minutes councilor Harvey
thank you thank you Deputy leader
um this isn't a grammatical issue it's
on page nine the resolution the first
part
refers to year three
a question whether that's accurate and I
think it should be year two if you
confirm or otherwise
would you just repeat that I was just
trying to find where you were at page
nine nine yeah resolved that
there's a reference to year three
and it should be year two I think it
should be year two
is that correct I don't if executive I
think it is oh sorry the resolution
absolutely captures it is for year three
in the Preamble it relates to year two
and yeah it should be year three it was
year three Council actions that we were
comparing against thank you
I'm so glad that we have that resolved
is that to your satisfaction councilor
Harvey
with that noting that Amendment for the
Preamble um may I take take it that the
minutes can be signed as a true and
accurate record of the meeting
agree thank you so much
we now move to what is item seven in our
agenda papers for members you are
looking at Pages 57 to 70 of your gender
papers land at Knights Lane tiddington
and the presenting officer is
sorry the presenting member I should say
is councilor Trevor Harvey councilor
Harvey
are seeking a steer from members of the
cabinet about the future of an asset
gifted to the council in 1957 which is
subject to a restrictive covenant
concerning the provision of a play area
the council received a letter in July
2015 in which the permanent under
Secretary of State at the then
Department of communities and local
government indicated that the relevant
Secretary of State proposed to direct
the council to dispose of the area of
land in question off Knights Lane
the council is therefore under an
obligation to dispose of this asset one
way or another in other words there's no
option of continuing to do nothing
the circumstances and options currently
identified for the future of this piece
of land are set out in the paper I look
forward to an exchange of views to which
I'm sure the officers will listen with
great interest thank you Mr Stupid
leader
thank you councilor Harvey at this point
um do any do Mr Perks do you want to
make any observations I know we have
some speakers it's whether you want to
make any observations now or after the
speakers
uh no I'd be interested to say here what
the speakers say personally
thank you very much I have two speakers
for this item noted I have counselor
Kate Rolfe I believe you're the ward
member covering this uh this particular
parcel of land and I have a Mr Charles
Gill
um
between you if you can work out who
wants to go first Mr Gill I'm I'm
obliged to tell you that our cancel
rules afford you three minutes to make
your points
and you have a timer and I have an
officer here with the timer as well
and I also apparently also I have a I
have a bond villain red button as well
apparently I can switch everything off
on us but don't worry I'll I'll leave
that for an elected member Kessler off
a cancer off you you're not subject to
the same restriction of three minutes
um but I'm sure that you will be uh
briefing to the point as usual
thank you
um so countless when I heard that this
piece of land had gone on the market and
that there was a potential buyer I
rallied the troops actually it wasn't
difficult to do so because people in
tiddington
are passionate about tinnington which is
why a lot of them are here and there are
some residents who have lived in
tiddington all their lives and remember
the gravel pit from then
this pit is a pit
in the middle of lots of houses with a
narrow pedestrian access between 43 and
45 Knights Lane both of the occupants of
those houses are here today
can you imagine a developer buying this
and trying to get houses on this piece
of land it's almost impossible and the
argument about upsetting and disturbing
natural biodiversity that has built up
over many decades will not go down well
with any of our planning policies I'm
sure
also if the buyer doesn't get planning
permission which he she won't I'm
absolutely ensure the land reverts back
to the district this could be a long way
down the road so giving it to the
villagers as soon as possible will make
everyone's lives a lot easier
we spoke to Tony perks who suggested
that we come up with a proposal for
residents in the village to look after
and maintain and use the Gravel Pit for
the benefit of the residents of
tiddington
a meeting was set up quickly as we knew
time was limited and over 30 people came
to the meeting and all put their names
down to register their interest in
looking after the pit
a few very knowledgeable people
including a biology teacher interested
in biodiversity put together the
proposal you have before you
and in fact if any of you want to see
the full proposal I have some spare
copies here you're very welcome to have
a look at them
the group also has a fundraising expert
in a local Village historian
this proposal was put together in a
matter of days as Tony perks gave us a
deadline which we adhered to did we not
Mr Perks
please give this group a chance by
opting for option 2.2 and investigating
further the handing over of this past of
land to a worthy group of people and the
village of tiddington
I was going to end there however about
an hour and a half ago I took a call
from some of you may know Jonathan
Thompson who deals with biodiversity Net
game projects
he's very keen on this he believes that
there are one or two credits on this
land and he has uh said to me that if
the village were to be lucky and have
this piece of land he will help them
with their biodiversity credits and it
does mean that money eventually and
credit goes back to this District
Council
so I I would urge you to seriously
consider allowing The Villages of the
village of tillington to take ownership
of this piece of land thank you
foreign
before I move to Mr Gill do any members
of cabinet have any immediate questions
for councilor Rolf if something comes up
further down the track after Mr Gillis
spoken I will afford a second
opportunity to question counselor Roth I
see councilor Parry
thank you and good afternoon councilor
of
um well I was particularly interested in
and the reason I'm sort of posing this
question to you because you're also not
only the war member but you're a town
councilor aren't you
um can you advise when this is put
forward
um were the Town Council given an
opportunity to bid for this and if so
being a town counts Town Council as well
um can you advise if you supported or
were encouraging them to take part in
the bid in order to give it back to the
to the residents of tillington because
normally when a pass of land often comes
up within the Town Council or Parish the
parish council or the Town Council
obviously are aware of it and certainly
in my ward I've had instances where a
parish council will put in a bid to
safeguard an area of green space so it'd
be really helpful to know
if you did approach the Town Council and
what the town council's response because
I I do believe the Town Council has
significant reserves and would have the
well with with all to purchase such a
piece of land thank you uh thank you uh
councilor Perry yes I did talk to the
Town Council it was a difficult time
because we there was a changeover of of
um Town Clark
um
to be honest with you when I discussed
it with the term Council it wasn't me
asking them if they'd be interested it
was me asking them if they'd support The
Villages of tillington to be honest I
did ask them if they would uh think
about it but they have
um a Parks commit uh Parks Services
people
um and they don't usually operate
outside the center of town
and the answer I got first time round
from Sarah Summers was that it's
probably better
if the village want to look after it
it's probably better because they have
much more local knowledge than the town
itself
can I just can I just come back yes I
can if if the town's Council were to
have purchased or put a bid in that may
or may not have been successful then
would they not have hoped that the
villagers they would they could have
given it as a gift to the villagers of
tiddington for tiddington they said they
certainly couldn't dump it they didn't
have the money
do I see any other questions at this
point counselor Harvey
um counter Roth can you confirm the
reserves of the sound council at the end
of last year were 402 000 pounds
sorry I'm having trouble hearing what
figure did you come up with
that I looked at this morning
accounts for the Town Council show that
it has reserves of four hundred and two
thousand pounds okay I don't sit on the
finance committee so I have no idea I
mean if you I I see where you're coming
from
um and totally understand it but but
actually this is something that is
really really special to The Villages of
tiddington it has nothing to do with the
Town Council The Villages of tinnington
want to take ownership of this pit they
do not want the Town Council because
actually if a Town Council run it The
Villages won't look after it if the
village have it the villages will look
after it
thank you in the absence of any other
questions for councilor Ralph at this
point I'm going to ask Mr Gill and I'm
sure you have your trusty timer ready
no it's just the uh the button that
would be on your your right it's the
button with the sort of a little bit of
a silvery all done thanks very much
right uh so three minutes ago so um my
name is Charles Gill I am a biology
teacher at Ulster grammar school and I
live in tiddington I'm also currently
the Royal Society of biology's national
teacher of the year and I sit on their
membership and engagement uh committee
largely for work in conservation I've
been involved in conservation projects
on every inhabited continent on the
planet as well as some in the UK most
recently around Ulster where I work
where I've been involved in similar
projects along with councilor Cargill
um so it doesn't come as a surprise to
anyone I'm sure you all know how nature
depleted how biodiversity depleted the
UK is and certainly very very
agricultural areas like Warwickshire
um if you've had a look at the magic map
application from defra you will have
seen how limited we are in terms of wild
space in the area
um I'm not going to sit here and read
the report we wrote to you but it
outlines all of the different taxes in
general that there are on this piece of
land and it is a real Haven for wildlife
um so we've got varieties of bats
starlings hedgehogs butterflies various
things on that are on various red
conservation lists uh up and down the
country
so the only thing substantively that's
changed since the writing of the report
of course is the Montreal biodiversity
conference where the UK committed to
being part of and not only part of but
cheering the 30 for 30 agenda which is
30 of our land and sea should be
protected for biodiversity by 2030. now
of course we all know how that works our
government our central government
commits to something and these things
roll down to local governments and
councils such as yourselves so this
place provides an easy win it also
provides a number of ecosystem services
to the uh to the area in terms of a a
Haven for pollinators for all the
agricultural land that is around us and
and a sort of stop-off for resting Birds
passive flood defense for
um because it is a gravel bottomed pit
so it's very very important for our
drainage
um and variety of other air purification
lowering of air pollution areas
understand that ecosystem services that
Parcels of land like this provide as
councilor roll for rightly said there
are also other areas where it can
contribute not just in terms of
aesthetic and cultural and historical uh
means to us but also in terms of funding
The Works of wildlife trust are
interested are interested in it the
residents formed it formed a group as
you'll hear more about biodiversity
credits I've also looked into through an
organization called environment Bank we
have funding experts on the potential
panel and of course I I'm not an expert
but the significant challenges of doing
anything else with it should be very
obvious to everyone we have a suitable
team set up to take this on we have all
the people and all the expertise that we
need to manage it at very little cost to
anyone
and hopefully down the road it could
even bring in benefits and biodiversity
for uh Stratford Council and all you
have to do to achieve that is nothing
three minutes
thank you very much
[Applause]
members of cabinet do you have any
questions for Mr Gill councilor Barker
uh yeah I'm just I just read through
your introduction in the report talking
about the previous owner who gifted SDC
the land with the intention that it
should continue to be an asset have you
are you aware of what it actually says
in the Covenant because I haven't read
the Covenant so I don't know
um was was that the intention is that
the wording yes it was left as I
understand it for the children of the
village and if I can put a Sentimental
spin on this I have recently just had
one who's one years old and I would very
much like him to grow up in an area
you haven't had a chance
who's
the biologist here uh
I'm pretty involved so
but as I say I would very much like him
to grow up in an area with access to
biodiversity and this area was left to
the children of tiddington and in this
new guise as a Wildlife Reserve it can
continue to be so
foreign
thank you does anybody else have any
other questions if not I'm going to ask
Mr Perks to to make some observations if
you wouldn't mind just sticking around
at the front in case any further
questions come up and then after that
we'll get into a discussion and debate
about the uh about the the paper Mr
Perks
uh thank you um Deputy leader
um I don't disagree with anything that
either of our speakers have sort of said
that or what set open the report we have
received a piece of land I understand it
was gifted to us originally to create a
play area for tiddington
and before long before I worked here a
play area was put on a more appropriate
piece of land at the other end of
knights Lane and this land has been sort
of left sort of largely unused sort of
presumably since 1957.
um the chronology which the report sets
out was we'd sat sort of quite happily
sort of doing nothing with the land
until a resident of tiddington
approached us a few years ago sort of
suggesting that we weren't using it
properly and that we should sell it to
him
um we resisted that and ended up with
the notice of disposal from the
secretary of state which has sort of
triggered several marketing exercises
the most recent of which was quite
fruitful where we were made an offer a
significant sort of amount of cash 133
000 pounds for the sides
and as cancer Rolf said that sort of
inspired the residents of tiddington
sort of into action to put together an
alternative proposal now under the
council's land disposal rules I am sort
of bound to sort of make best use of
council sort of land and sort of get as
much as I can
um the sort of best consideration for
disposal
there is a provision within the Cancer's
land disposal rules in certain
circumstances that the cabinets request
I can look at alternative ways to use
that land for social sort of economic
well-being of the communities
so really I think what we're here today
to discuss is um do we wish to proceed
with the sale which would give you 133
000 pounds which you could use for the
good of The Wider District or for
anything the council fit or are we
prepared to sort of forego that and I
would if you are minded to try and
transfer the land to the sort of
residence here there would be quite a
bit of work still to do we'd need to
sort of set up the constituted body and
we'd have to sort of find a sort of a
way that the residents could hold the
land whether it be at least Freehold or
that there would be there would be work
to do and I I hadn't yet done that work
because before spending a lot of my
office's time sort of doing that I
wanted to steer really as to which way
we wanted to go with it so I think your
options today are set out in the
reporter either to decide to proceed
with the sale the offer that we have on
the table or to send me away to come up
with an alternative proposal which may
or may not be feasible sort of going
forward I hope that's useful
thank you Mr Perks I think councilor
Harvey and then councilor Barker now
thank you could ask
um Mr Grafton to remind councilors of
what our legal obligations are in
relation to the custody of assets please
am I on yeah okay yeah so um Tony's
already referred to something called the
land disposal procedure rules which is a
published document which is um forms
part of the council's Constitution
um so the first and foremost legal
obligation is
um under what's called a fiduciary duty
that all councilors have and that is to
secure value for money when disposing of
land
um and normally to obtain best
consideration in other words the market
value for the land
now having said that
there are exceptions to obtaining best
value
and one of them is around
um
where the disposal of the land is for
the purpose of and I'm going to quote
that it's likely to contribute to the
achievement or promotion or Improvement
of the economic social or environmental
well-being of the whole or part of the
district or some or all of its residents
and you need to have
um pay attention to the community
strategy making that decision
so as Tony said earlier it's it's a
choice that you have normally you would
be looking for the market value of the
property but in cases where that legal
principle applies you can depart from
best value
foreign
ordinarily you're not allowed to ask
questions but I'm sure that somebody
might want to ask you a question to find
out what you were going to ask us
I have councilor Barker next and then I
have counselor Rock who is sitting in as
the um for the opposition group in place
of councilor junid and then I have
councilor kettle
um I've got two
questions
um first of all the individual or
company that's offered money for the
site
do we have any idea what they want to do
with it and would it still be a
nature Refuge of some description
and then secondly I've actually got a
question from Mr Gill which I shall come
back with after I've heard the answer to
that one
um we we don't have a definite plan I
think they're looking to hold it as a
development site they are aware that it
won't be an easy development site
because the access to it is very limited
it's got a sort of significant crater in
it where the gravel was extracted from
and there would be a number of planning
issues to overcome as well as the legacy
of the restricted Covenant resolve all
of those things were made quite clear in
the particulars of sale and this bid is
sort of based on on that situation so to
that extent I've answered your question
but I I couldn't handle hard to do their
entire intentions but the fact that we'd
sold it if that's the decision that
cabinet were to reach today wouldn't
make it any more or less likely to
obtain planning permission all of those
controls would remain uninfluenced by
this decision
um can I just before just to remind
members whilst no member of the cabinet
sits on planning committee
um I think you know uh so our cost
councilor Parry I do apologize
okay
as most of you are on planning committee
can I just uh ensure that you all stay
the right side of the line in terms of
anything that might at all be considered
around predetermination of any future
possible planning application you all
have your planning hours and you're all
very well versed in it but it is still
my job to remind you otherwise the legal
officer across the way who's nodding
furiously well with a smile on his face
uh will will tell me off and I think um
councilor Barker did you want to come
back again with a second I had a second
one and um girl might be able to answer
this one if we're talking in terms of
biodiversity credits have you any idea
what the estimate of credits would be on
this site and how ah or all councilor
Roth might be able to answer that I see
her just just so we have an idea of that
biodiversity actual value which I know
can be converted into pounds
um as I said earlier two hours ago had a
long conversation with Jonathan Thompson
so you are looking at some if if there's
two credits there you're looking at
somewhere in the region of 30 000 per
credit
should you wish yes so I've also spoken
with um some environmental credit fund
uh funding providers like environment
Banks specifically everyone called
Elizabeth daily uh Dolby there largely
they work with larger Parcels of land
but she had uh said that the typical
term of environmental credit
um schemes is about 30 years so you
wouldn't be getting certainly 133 000
pounds on year one but in terms of the
term of any biodiversity plan over time
you probably especially when you add in
the ecosystem services and the various
costs you could offset mitigating harm
of other developments in the area you
could well easily be looking at
exceeding that figure over the term of
any biodiversity project with my
conservationist hat on
that was the answer I was looking for
thank you and and may I just add to that
councilor Barker that I mean obviously
Jonathan the conversation two hours ago
he doesn't know much about it he's
looked at the area and the plans and he
has promised that he will work because
he's locally lives around the corner
that the residents didn't know I about
this but he has promised that he will
work with the residents free of charge
to ensure that they get the best deal
possible
you couldn't really say any more could
you
okay thank you thank you um I now have
counselor Rock
uh thank you chairman
um I I have a sort of an addendum to the
question that um
uh was asked about the legal position uh
from our legal advisor in the corner
there
um it's my understanding that if we were
dealing with normal commercial
bits we use something a best available
value which doesn't necessarily mean
that it's always the cheapest or the
most uh or the the best income for the
council so I'm just wondering if that is
uh an additional consideration that um
is uh possible or relevant and the
second point is presumably if the
council just decide to dispose it in any
way a legal covenant could be applied in
future about the use of the land
restrictive covenant is is that
something that is possible just for the
information of the executive of the
cabinet so I think turning to your first
point I think the message from uh Mr
Grafton is that uh assured cabinet be
minded there is sufficient wiggle room
within the land disposal policy
um to look at an alternate option to the
one that is before us in terms of the
the offer on the table in terms of your
second question I think I'm going to
defer to Mr perks or Mr Buckland
um
the two questions sort of run sort of in
tandem I think what you're referring to
in your first question is sort of the
way we would evaluate a tender return
generally that we would attach some sort
of
a number of points to sort of price a
number of points to the social value or
the sort of the quality of the bid
that's not quite applicable to sort of
um dispersals of land where really the
only sort of consideration is price
unless the cabinet choose to exercise
their social value due to the sort of Mr
Grafton has described to you and I think
I sort of alluded to earlier in my
presentation
um moving to your second Point we've um
secured the offer that's on the table
that the cabinet is considering today on
the basis of a set of particulars that
showed the restrictive covenant and it
showed the restrictions of the land it
didn't show any new covenants being
attached by The District Council so that
would be a different Prospect of sale so
um whilst I I suppose a potential
outcome would be we could withdraw it
and re-advertise it for sale on a
different basis that isn't really what
the cabinets are here to consider today
and if that's a direction the cabinet
would like to take
um we'd probably just need a moment to
reflect on how we would achieve that
thank you Mr Perks I now have counselor
kettle
thank you Mr chairman
um
what are my first question is what are
the terms of the restrictive covenant
um we can presumably those will flow
through with any ongoing sale
I know there's a certain ones in here
but as is there anything we can add to
that uh which will demonstrate
um if we can have that answer and then
I've got two follow-on ones after that
I think Mr Perks has said we can't add
anything we'd have to start again I
think you you've got you've got it on
the top you've got an offer and
acceptance on the table so I think uh
it's a follow-on from councilor rocks
Point uh I think you'd be having to
market the site again is what Mr Perks
is saying
um yes to impose any sort of further
restrictive covenants you would
certainly need to market the site to
gain
um I think speaking to your first point
about the existing Covenant councilor
Kettle it I'm not really offering legal
advice here but my understanding is that
it's a personal Covenant so
um
areas it's a complex area without a
restrictive covenants and we'd be sort
of Tied by this if we were trying to
impose one if you don't have land that
touches and concerns and things like
that it's quite difficult to enforce
covenants and with personal covenants
they tend to in some instances sort of
die with the with the owner of the
Covenant we've been quite open with the
um the bidders about that we haven't
given a viewers to the validity of the
Covenant or its enforceability we've
allowed the um prospective purchase to
sort of reach their own views on it so
we're not offering any sort of legal
advice about that
councilor Kettle I think you have
another sorry my follow-on for that is
if we as a council acquired it with a
restrictive covenant on it
does that restrictive covenant not
continue uh if we were to transfer it
onto a third party I'm not talking about
adding any restrictive covenants but
what how
um it says it may only be used as a play
area
um although it's not being used as
players and that was sort of it's a
sorry
cancel I was just taking some advice uh
just not I was just making sure we're
not straying into anything around a
planning application but I'm I'm told
that your your line is okay
thank you
um
sitting next to the council's legal off
so hopefully you might be able to tell
us a bit more
surely if there is a restrictive
government requiring it kept us a play
area that will transfer and flow through
to any future owner and therefore the
ability of any future trailer to develop
this would be restricted by the fact
that restrictive government says it is a
play area
um Mr Grafton
Mr Grafton and then Mr Perks by the
looks of things I think I'm going to
have to defer to Mr Perks because I've
not actually seen the legal conveyance
I think the strict answer to your
question cancer cattle is the Covenant
will flow with the transfer of the land
what we haven't offered an opinion on is
whether that Covenant is currently
enforceable and whether it would be
enforceable on future owners of the land
thank you do you have a further question
or can I move to councilor shenton no we
we then go on to questions
um for the local team as it were
um
looking at it on Google Earth
um this is a landlocked in fact the
report says is it a landlocked site
um and one of the
um key issues about
biodiversity of sustainability is having
the ability for wildlife to move in and
move out to a site to have Avenues
whether it be lines of hedgerows lines
of trees Brooks whatever
um
this is very much encircled both by
tarmac and properties
um in your knowledge could you explain
to me how we get over that
slight contradiction between what I
normally see as a wildlife sustainable
site and what we have here
that sounds like a biology question for
me
um so yeah the the taxonomic
biodiversity in that area particularly
focuses on bats birds and flying insects
which of course don't care about tarmac
and don't care about things there are of
course lots of terrestrial animals
hedgehogs things like that move in and
out when they move in through Gardens
which they have very easy access to do
but the the real sort of assets there
are if you look at we've got our house
sparrows and starlings in there which
are on the rspb's red conservation list
we've got four or four just from casual
um sort of studying of the backed
populations there there's three or four
different species of bat which obviously
are threatened and declining across the
UK there are a number of species of
butterflies that fly in and these CR
these species particularly the smaller
ones they need islands where they can
feed where they can stop where they can
Roost as we know things like starlings
and migratory birds and they have a
range across the UK but they have
declined I think it is 50 in the last uh
20 years from the r rspb's website I
think it's previously 30 percent of
their chicks could be expected to reach
a year now it's down to 15 and this is
put down supposedly to areas where they
are migrating around they can't find to
stop because to them a field is a desert
and a Motorway is a desert these little
islands that we can provide for them
actually benefit from being landlocked
because it reduces their predation
increases their food sources and uh you
know especially allows them these sort
of Havens between areas the nearest ones
if you look at the the map on the on the
magic map the defra feature the nearest
places they could get to the North would
be in the welcome Hills there's a few
stands of of Woodland there and then up
to the off to the South and the East
you've got Loxley Woods other than that
you've got town and you've got farmland
so so basically yeah the the type the
landlock I think is an advantage rather
than a problem for biodiversity
thank you very much Mr Gill uh you have
a further question I think I'm going to
cut it at that councilor Kettle because
you've had a significant bite it's a
number of cherries there and I think I
do need to in I've got councilor shenton
and councilor Parry waiting very
patiently cancel the kettle
right final Point clearly the main
beneficiaries of this being kept
retained as a Wildlife Reserve one of
the principal benefits will be the local
residents
um but they have not yet managed to to
raise any money whatsoever to put
forward an offer for this that seems to
me peculiar given that many many other
communities when there is something
important for them they do manage the
club together and put some sort of fund
which will be able to put forward this
doesn't appear to have happened here
um and therefore we have there'll be a
significant benefit if it's retained and
not if it were to be put to another use
um but um you know that the money we
raised from here could be used in doing
biodiversity work elsewhere
that I can answer that if it's a brief
because I do want to I don't want to get
into it absolutely brief the residents
had the meeting and we decided that we
wouldn't look at they're all willing to
put money in believe me but we're not
going to do it until we know
until we know whether we are likely to
get the land I mean why why would we but
there's certainly money within the
village that will look after that land
in perpetuity
thank you counselor of councilor shenton
thank you Deputy leader um
this is more of by way of commentary
rather than questions if that's okay
okay
so
I look at this the way I see this is
that we it was gifted to the The
Authority so it's actually cost us
nothing uh in in any case
the there is a restrictive covenant on
there which could be or might not might
or might not be problematic
I hear the biodiversity
gains to be from this piece of land I
also look at this peace line I know
where this is because I used to work at
the nfu mutual next door as I know you
did
so I am aware of where this land is it
is fairly well Locked In by houses on
all sides and my apologies to anybody
who just heard me hit the mic there
um
so I
I'm in the position where I I'm thinking
well what could happen What could this
land be used for would it be better
um use of it to be a wildlife
area if you like a natural area
or do we sell it to somebody and we
don't know what's going to happen to
this
now
I I feel
the the thing the only thing that really
troubles me I suppose if we transferred
it to the residence is as councilor
kettles raised the funding isn't in
place maybe yet I know councilor Ralph
has said that there there is funding
so I think if we went down that route of
transferring it to the residents and I
have no no great uh issue with that
um I would still want to see that we we
there was a period of time where we
could see if the money is actually there
rather than
um if you like a a a a a a a a a a
comment by councilor off so I'd like to
see that the money is there that the
constitution is there and that the the
whole thing is set up correctly before
the transfer so I I in principle I don't
have a problem with with that
as far as the the um less than
commercial value goes we've already
heard there's exceptions to that so we
don't fall of any rules there and I'm
quite quite happy with that I'd like to
know a little bit more about that
restrictive covenant as well but we are
where we are at the moment and so for me
it's making sure that if we do transfer
it that the residents have will do put
the money into it that it is constituted
correctly
sorry I have councilor Parry I have
councilor Barker and then in the absence
of that I have I have some questions of
my own
councilor parrot thank you Deputy leader
my my question's really one for
um Mr Perks
um I'm particularly interested I mean uh
Stratford District Council certainly
um has done a lot to support tiddington
and to the new residence because we've
supported the football club in the past
so we're very much aware of the role
tiddington
if I might just ask members of the
public it's a public meeting it's not a
participation meeting please allow
members of cabinet to express their
views and and let us have an
understanding and a debate about it if
you don't mind thank you what I'm
particularly interested to know from Mr
Perks is has Stratford District Council
had any history of giving a gift of this
value to a to another Town Council or a
parish
of this significant size because at the
end of the day we have an offer on the
table of 133
000 pounds the Town Council
haven't come forward to help and
um
and and we at this moment in time we
have no contribution or any indication
of what perhaps it would be worth to the
tiddington residents and my my other
point was in view of various questions
put forward during this meeting is there
any Merit to defer this item in order to
find out a little bit more information
and have this come back to the next
cabinet meeting thank you if you if
you'll hold that thought I have
counselor Barker and I virtually have
councilor Cargill can't uh no before
that I have Mr Perks to respond to uh
councilor Parry I do apologize told you
I wasn't very good with technology
um thank you counselor Perry
pointed in the right direction so
everyone can hear
um
there are two schemes that spring to
mind off the top of my head where there
is there are that are comparable with
this we did
um in conjunction with Ulster Town
Council we did a fields in trust
application I think it was to celebrate
the Queen's Jubilee Ulster Nature
Reserve where I think we retained
ownership of the land but we um that we
entered into sort of apologies my lack
of diesel I wasn't prepared for the
question some sort of lease arrangement
with the Ulster Town Council on that and
the other one that Springs to mind is a
player in wilmcoat where we granted a
lease to a sort of community body
um I think back to that instance by the
parish council for use as a play area
um it was a sort of public
a public coming together with some money
looking to sort of invest in some play
equipment looking for sites in within
Wilmette so we did agree at least with
them so there is
some Preston they're not directly
Parable comparable the full gift of land
and on your second point yesterday
cabinet today are minded to sort of want
to look at this further
um I can sort of get my team just to
work with the with the representatives
of the group to see if there's a legal
mechanism by which we could transfer it
we could bring some options back to the
cabinet if that's if that's your wish
but I don't wish to preempt your
decision
perks Mr Buckland did you want to make a
comment yeah just in relation to those
two examples that Tony just mentioned
both of which had a formerly constituted
body that the council did an agreement
with as I understand it at present
there is no formal Constitution
constituated body but it's something
that we could pick up in our in our
further investigations
thank you very much Mr Buckland I have
councilor Barker then I have virtual
counselor Cargill
um I just want to make the point is I
spent a large amount of my pupilage
working on restrictive covenants and
let's just not get into them hey
um they can be worked with but it's
above our pay grade frankly we will
leave that to people who really
understand it because it is a nightmare
um the consideration needed for this
site is something that I'm a little
concerned about hence I asked the
question about biodiversity credits I'm
equally concerned we don't want to set a
precedent for giving land away
and the final point is actually a
question who owns the access because is
it a ransom strip to somebody else
Mr Perks can you help
uh yes
um I agree with your point of
restrictive covenants
um I shall make no further comments on
that
um in terms and again I think your
comment on precedent speaks for itself
in terms of the access my understanding
is the axis is owned by SDC but is
subject to a number of access licenses
um that benefits the two residences on
either side of the access
um if you want more detail on that I can
provide it but that's the general
situation none needed
councilor Cargill
thank you chair no comments actually uh
I think it would be well worth
um referring this to subsequent uh
reports because I think it's a huge
benefit to the community and if we can
make this one work then I would say yes
on the other hand we are in Dire Straits
regard finances so as far as I'm
concerned I would like to see a little
bit more information on some if I may
but I'm minded to consider it going to
the community yes
councilor Harvey and then I'll I have
some questions of my own
this is a very straightforward question
to Mr Grafton
um
we've heard that there are other
arrangements which involved a lease
if a lease was granted in relation to
this instance would that in your view
meet the requirements for disposal of
the Department of local communities and
local government as it was at the time
yeah Elise is considered to be a
disposal
thank you very much
councilor off last chance please vote so
that's so good it does actually State
how they're going to set up a
constituted body so all those questions
it's all in here if you've had time to
read it and it's something that we're
happy the residents are happy to discuss
further along the line with Mr Perks
thank you
um so I'm going to make a couple of
observations and I've got a couple of
questions and I'm probably going to
direct them to Mr Gill rather than you
counselor off
so
we find ourselves on the horns of a
dilemma in that
we have
what on the face of it seems to be a
good offer for a piece of land and that
money could then be used to benefit
district-wide the residents and that
money could be used to achieve some of
our climate and biodiversity aims across
the piece
against that
as we sit here right at this moment we
have the hope that a community group
could be coordinated could bring itself
together could put together a business
case that could deliver
a biodiversity site and have benefits
through the use of offsetting credits
amongst others to create some revenue
for the district council to support the
services that it needs to deliver and to
achieve some of its climate and
biodiversity goals
and the difficulty we have at the minute
is as I see it
um we have certainty versus
hope that's that's the decision we have
at the minute as far as I can see
um
I've not heard anything that tells me
that this site would not
um
be suitable for accruing credits as far
as I understand yes it would
so there is the possibility there
um
and I do observe
um that
um it is disappointing to say the very
least that another arm of public of of
local government
um actually based in the town and I take
that Teddington is a is a village but to
all intents and purposes it's it's part
of stratford-upon-avon and the Town
Council not wanting to come to this
party at all I find quite disappointing
because I think there clearly could have
been a there clearly could have been a
way with the Town Council involved I
made that observation I I think that
suggesting that it's in the difficult
box because it's not quite Stratford tan
I'm frankly not buying that so the
question for me Mr Gill is
to persuade this committee to go with
hope
we have somebody who's prepared to part
with the cash they won't wait forever
realistically how how long do would you
take to get a business case get your
organization constituted have some
something ready with potential finances
to back it
for Mr Perks to evaluate against what we
have in our hand
you raise an excellent point about time
and a lot of the things I'm not uh you
know a politician or a lawyer but the
amount of time that we've had to
constitute an organization involve the
Town Council so on and so forth has
simply not been there
um as far so as far as those sort of
conversations go yes they certainly
could be have it happening but they just
haven't had the chance and to put to
come back onto safer territory for me
from the biodiversity Point let's say
you got your 133 000 pounds for it and
let's say you were minded to use that
money for biodiversity Creation in other
parts of the district successional
processes as in the processes that
generate biodiversity by which nature
builds layers of biodiversity in an area
are slow if you try and move
biodiversity it is almost always
unsuccessful and
of um in terms of hs2s biodiversity
offsetting and all this kind of stuff
the like the analogy I've heard used is
it's like taking a woodland and putting
it in a blender and then expecting that
to be the same about biodiversity when
you put it somewhere else it doesn't
work that like that so successional
processes are slow but the other good
things come to your other point is they
are free
they do happen with no cost so the
management costs of this we're talking
about who's going to manage it how much
it's going to cost very very little all
right sensitive hands-off nature
management I've managed to achieve in
places like Madagascar the second
poorest country on the planet where
people are living hand to mouth and they
can manage to preserve biodiversity for
an absolute pittance of money coming in
from uh you know from other parts of the
world with much
this one here
follow up on that so how long have you
had to get yourself sorted to get to
this point how long has it taken you to
get to your uh Constitution Etc Tony
perks gave us three weeks
three weeks in order to set up a meeting
to set up a committee and to set up this
proposal three weeks that's all we have
that just proves that incentives Drive
behavior and I think that that is
um I think we have yeah no but when
you've got an incentive it does Drive
Behavior so where we are at at the
moment is counselor Parry did I take
that as a as a proposal to defer for
some further work I I would like to put
forward a proposal to defer for some
further work to give them an opportunity
to for us to have a have some more
information in front of us do I have a
second for that I have councilor shenton
seconding that
um I'm just going to
I'm happy to take that I am going to
just ask uh Mr Perks whether uh where
I'm thinking about is whether we should
have some timeline around that again
uh deadlines and incentive strike
behavior and I am I am also conscious
that we have
Gone Part way down the road with a
potential buyer and there is an element
of needing to be fair and reasonable Mr
Perks do you have any thoughts on
timelines to get something back to a
subsequent cabinet I appreciate that
maybe a sort of
back of the proverbial [ __ ] packet
um yes
um we have the
funding issue of the election coming up
and go moving to Purdue which may
restrict decision so I'm looking
probably you've got a meeting on the 6th
of March
which
probably looking at Mr Grafton would be
the probably the latest meeting at which
we can make a decision at this side of
the election
so if we could
get some sort of work done in that time
but where are we on we're January at the
moment aren't we so we yeah we could
bring an update to the 6th of March so I
think from your perspective Mr Gill that
sort of gives you circus six weeks to
start pulling your team together
um and to be in a position where there's
a this you know in Broad terms what will
be described as a business proposal
can I make the point it's not my team
it's uh it's a team of it's a team of
residents and where we are one we are
one team and if you give us some
parameters of what you want because as I
say I'm not a politician or a lawyer
then sure we'll get to work I think that
I was just going to say if Mr Perks
could give us what He requires we will
work on okay well I think let's uh we
haven't taken a vote yet but I I have no
doubt that if if that is where cabinet
is going that it that an early
discussion between Mr Perks and the team
and Mr Perks
um yeah I don't wish to sort of pour oil
on dump in people's bonfires what are
the right metaphor is but just I do
think it's important that I say that I
can't guarantee that if we delay
um until that time that the offer will
still be on the table from the
commercial party so just making sure the
cabinet are I'm not saying it's going
away or threatening people but I just
felt that was a relevant fact that you
need to have in your minds as you make
the decision so you've got both sides of
the story for the fairness purposes so
members of cabinet you have before you a
proposal that we defer
a decision on the disposal of this
parcel of land
before I go further counselor
thank you Deputy chair the the the
deputy leader so
um
the only problem I I've got at this
point that we we wrote in to defer is
that we don't know what we're deferring
for as such that's where I was going
sorry I'll step back
if only there was there were two options
that were presented to the cabinet day
the first option was that you agreed to
perceive the sale the second option
which is on page 58 of the agenda 2.2 to
ask officers to investigate whether the
land could be transferred to the
residence for uses of nature reserve
that's why we we understand that the
deferment is for that those discussions
to take place
councilor Barker
sorry this is just a really brief one
but nobody's actually really mentioned
cash so at some point the residents will
have to have discussed with them but
there will be any cash forthcoming
I think that
the message for residents is that
um if if the residents are putting
forward a case for the transfer of the
land for it to be a reserve it's things
like biodiversity credits it's things
you know it's it's how and that is you
know frankly that is the Dilemma we have
you know about
um you know we do need to try and get a
return in some way and that's a broad
term that does include the impact on
biodiversity but
um I think that you've just gotta my
steer to you if this is where this goes
is you've you've you've got to think
innovatively about how can we ensure
that
um you know this achieves something both
in terms of biodiversity and has the
happy Coincidence of you know for
example some Revenue through uh through
credits or some other means
and ready money yes
the possibly ready money indeed it may
be that they decide to come up with
ready money yeah absolutely right I'm
trying to make it as broad as possible
there
I think I had counselor Harvey and then
I've got you councilor Kettle very
quickly my
the terms of 2.2 refer to transfer my
question to Mr Grafton revolver and the
possibility of release I hope that that
word transferred includes the
possibility the consideration of the
possibility of a lease
I'm sure that it does cancel a kettle
I was just going to oversize Council
Barker comment
um and going back to council Parry said
earlier on residents of this immediate
area of Stratford have had some benefit
previously
um
right
um and I think there should be a
financial commitment but forward uh
where there is consideration they're
prepared to offer in some form to this
Council I think as far as we can go is
we're going to investigate this I think
that members of the group hear the
concerns and constraints that this
Authority Works under and I would just
suggest about being Innovative about how
you come with Solutions
um and I don't think we can ask for any
commitment for Hard Cash rights at this
second although counselor Barker would
wish me to I think we are the the if we
are we are investigating whether the
land can be transferred and the
financials are part and parcel of
investigating whether the land can be
transferred I'm not sure we can go much
further at this point in corral in that
into a particular corner
okay uh it was the thing that nobody
wanted to mention now we've mentioned
cash absolutely
does anybody else have any observation
because at the moment I have um what is
in essence a proposer and a second uh
for a deferral based around the wording
in section 2.2 on page 58 of our agenda
papers councilor shenton
yeah just to back up what I was I was
getting at before councilor Barker has
hit the nail right on the head it is
about funding
with that members of cabinets you have
an immense you have a you have a
proposal before you which is that our
officers are tasked with investigating
whether the land could be transferred to
tiddington residents for use as a nature
reserve and the back back story to that
is about what it could be how it can be
funded what revenue streams there could
be members or those in favor of us we do
because it was councilor shenton who had
set and did I don't just throw this
stuff together chief executive thank you
well it appears that I do and its
appearances are all correct
members of cabinet all those in favor
please share
that's agreed unanimously so
you're looking quizzically biology
teacher of the year you've won well
you've at least got to a replay
so uh you uh I think if you if you and
your team can make contact with
councilor perks
officer perks
I blame the technology I do I just it's
always the technology
um get make contact with Mr Perks and
you can agree the parameters of your
homework when it's got to be in for and
what's going to get you a pass mark
it I'm assuming those are in terms that
you you were quite used to there Mr Gill
yeah you use them adequately
thank you very much they don't just pass
at ages though
well of course of course and what I'm
now going to do is I'm going to call a
quick break because I'm imagining that a
number of you want to be off to your
real world so can we just tool up a
quick break and take the
thing Dan thank you very much
foreign
thank you um
I'm finding this a bit loud in my own
ears does it work if I have it at that
angle I'm sorry to be so prissy well I
don't know if I'm like that I'm like
[Music]
but am I too loud for you
oh extraordinary
um the technical term
used it many times
um this notification on cost of living
the cost of living crisis has certainly
um
been
part of what has informed the budget
process whether we consulted the notice
emotional not as we were doing it is
another matter because I can tell you
that as we read through the background
information on page 11.
um particularly raising the issue of
rural areas where people use gas
solid fuel bottled gas oil and that that
isn't covered with some of the Caps that
have been introduced we're certainly
looking at plans for that and I and I'm
really grateful that the officers have
been thanked for all the things that
they are processing for us
um
we have reviewed the council tax
reduction scheme which works extremely
well at present
um and we were we are satisfied and that
featured in the budget as you'll
discover when councilor Harvey
goes through it
um ways to protect fundings for
partnership you will also notice that we
have put money into citizens advice act
on energy and as per page
107
you will discover that 250 000 pounds
per year
has been put towards a cost of living
support fund yet to be completely agreed
and worked out how but be ready for a
very very exciting project
so I think we've knocked all that on oh
yes and we will be supporting um food
banks where they
um apply for money I can say that it's
unlikely that my own food bank will
apply because we rely entirely on
voluntary contributions and are doing
okay as I suspect many of us are
um
so what I would like to concentrate on
now is the fact that
uh the second element of 1.1 where you
ask the leader to write to the to
ministers
um to relieve the cost of living crisis
Etc by investing in Renewables I'm
asking cabinet that we don't write that
letter it's not in my view relevant to
what we're doing here we do
decarbonisation anyway and we've got
those decarbonization projects that's
just um well more than a cherry on top
of the icing and we have iced quite
sufficiently so I would ask that to
consider the motion
um and that we accept it
save the council also asks to network in
the long term be deleted
thank you Kevin
thank you very much
um any other members of cabinet I was
I've got a couple of observations any
other members of cabinet before
um so I think councilor Barker you're
talking about accepting the motion save
for writing to uh central government I
would observe that
um there is a there is a reference here
that uh talks about
um
increasing you UK Renewables
um has an immediate impact on reducing
costs well it doesn't it was the whole
of that paragraph I want deleted and
we're not writing the other part is I'm
assuming that we are not looking to
alter the council tax reduction scheme
uh I'm not sure we should be putting the
county 4 million could in the whole over
five five years
um that's not a great look
um and actually the law of unintended
consequences applies that four million
quid
is money that then wouldn't be able to
be spent on the most deprived families
across the county I just point out that
we've been asked to review it okay so
we're very happy to move review did okay
so but it's a reviewing to leave it as
it is uh and I mean it is in the context
of
um you know we as we'll be seeing from
the budget papers
um we are looking at some
ways where we can actually find ways of
putting money into people's pockets and
making a real difference to their lives
bearing in mind we are a small District
Council and we don't not even we don't
even have the uh the wherewithal to be
clear it is just that one paragraph to
be deleted
that's there's a proposal there from uh
councilor Barker do I have a second
therefore for that
councilor Perry is that agreed
thank you very much
next on page 17 notice of motion cutting
of Highway verges and the lead Office
Accounts is counselor I keep I keep
demoting Mr Perks to councilor perks uh
and the uh the lead member is uh uh
councilor shenton
um subbing for the
glad to see you returned councilor
Fleming you know just back into uh good
to see you back in uh in harness and uh
in uh one or more pieces but glad to see
you back but holding the rounds for you
today on this one worshiping off
councilor shenton
thank you Deputy leader it's come as a
surprise because I wasn't actually
expecting to speak on this
um and so I might
defer to to council Fleming and and Tony
perks but what I will say is that we
have been looking at this uh for some
time with County
um and uh
it makes it makes perfect sense to
rewild certain verges around the the uh
the county obviously there are
restrictions The Verge policy does go
into that
uh what the restrictions are but we only
act as the agent in many ways for the
county on on cutting so I I
um I'm actually in favor of this I will
say right at the outset um I am in favor
of this because of the work that's been
done and the number of organizations
that have been involved with County on
on this County have adopted this Verge
policy it is uh it is up and running so
other than that I I'm quite happy to
defer to Tony perks on on this matter
um councilor Rock do you have any
comments observations on this particular
one and I apologize uh I I failed to ask
you I uh about the previous item with
you had any comments or observations and
that was that was just million
oversights on my part oh thank you for
your courtesy chairman I didn't have any
comments to make so I I the decision was
noted
um and thank you for giving me the
opportunity uh uh on this particular
item
um I'm I'm now turning to the page I I I
failed to Mark earlier on but I'll ask
my question on the hoof
um I found it on page 46 of the uh of
the the
The Berkshire County council's
um is it a policy or methodology anyway
the good um the guide
um and uh I agree with what councilor
shenton said this is and uh I think
that's a positive response
um
the particular thing we're interested in
is is always the difficult areas and on
page 46 it talks about those three
difficult areas
um
of particular hostile plants
particularly giant hogweed which we we
have had a problem with in the district
and it mentions that uh really it gives
the Pres impression that bio herbicides
are generally avoided by various means
giant hogweed appears to be the
exception
uh I'm aware that the council uses
glycophosphate in control of some uh
areas and I'm just wondering if that is
something
officers
could consider is the the elimination of
glycophosphate I know it's not
particularly
black and white issue but a number of
authorities are trying to avoid the use
of
glycophosphate as a control medium
because of the health
um
difficulties Associated within human
health so uh
I asked the cabinet and officers do
consider if we can avoid the use of
glycophosphate and if not uh you know
what other substitutions are there and
is there a better way of doing it but
apart from that I have no comment thank
you chairman
Mr Perks you have any observation on
that and then I've got councilor shenton
again
um yes specifically on the control of
giant hogweed we use
um an expert as is our duty under the
invasive weeds act or whatever the
correct title of that is
um to control that um we we can have
discussions with that to contracture
about what the least sort of damaging
way of um sort of balancing the harm
that John hogweed causes because it
causes burning the skin is quite a
nastic lines if you come into contact
with it
um it is chemical treatment is the
recommended way of sort of managing that
um but we can ensure that it's done with
the least harmful chemicals I can give
that commitment
yeah I just wanted to I'd say that
notwithstanding
um cancer rocks
comments about giant hogweek this The
Verge policy
um is about rewilding and the principle
of communities getting involved in
rewilding and not about the specifics of
chemicals
okay councilor kettle
I was just going to come back on a glass
of phosphate
um it is
um there's an awful lot of media chat
about
um this particular chemical
um some of which is accurate some of
which is significantly inaccurate
um clearly the
um
abundant use of any chemical needs to be
controlled and I think to put limits or
a seek to put limits on contractors who
may be using the best cut
chemical available
in the right circumstances that should
be the way we should go forward we
should not be dictating to experts which
chemical they do and do not use
there are lots of academic studies
saying uh glass phosphate will normally
more commonly there's a Roundup is very
bad but also quite a lot of academic
studies which say which contradict that
um so I think we need to be very careful
thank you I think uh it was an
observation for us to adopt the best
practice rather than be prescriptive uh
Mr Grafton I think he'd indicated
yes thank you so um
we need to remember that this came
forward as a
emotion from Council
so in looking at the recommendation
which is back to council I think we just
want a little bit of wording perhaps at
the end of the sentence in the
recommendation that maybe confirms that
that is a positive response and
um complies with the notice of motion or
words to that effect
and if cabinet are comfortable with some
editorial license to the lead officer
along that I don't think we need to work
up the wording now
so I think we've got a proposer I've got
a seconder for
okay so is everybody in agreement that
we accept the motion back to council
agreed thank you very much now come to
Part B matters for decision by cabinet
uh legal and Community safety portfolio
number of development working group
incentives to undertake member training
and that is page 53 on your papers
um
personal observation is can we arrange
for 27 hours to be put into every day
that might give me a Fighting Chance
um I know that counselor Rolf has
indicated a wish to speak on this matter
and I've agreed that she can do so
um councilor Kettle you're the lead
member
um can you uh introduce the item
uh thank you Mr chairman
um
we have a lot of responsibility as
elected members to both make decisions
correctly on behalf of our residents but
also as they're representative to make
sure that we give them the best advice
possible at all times given that we are
amateurs not professionals
um but we are elected uh to support them
and therefore it is really important
that every member does their best to
understand the issues receive relevant
training and make sure that they they
can do their job as best they possibly
can
clearly some members work incredibly
hard
and absorb all that is necessary without
actually attending
training courses that are put forward
but there are some for whom that does
not apply
uh and there are some who are definitely
a little bit short on training ours who
do not put the R's in and of what you
might call
getting that information uh through
osmosis I suppose it's correct
uh description uh so
the route we're going forward is let us
see let us try and encourage as many
members through their groups
to commit to doing as much training as
they can within the constraints of uh we
do only have 24 hours a day but I will
speak to Mr dorby uh to see if we can
extend the Working Day to 27 hours which
I'm sure will make councilmemberton feel
much happier thank you very much I would
correct you uh councilor Kettle we're
not amateurs we're gifted amateurs
um and I might also could we add to a
recommendation that the deputy leader is
provided with a DeLorean uh that might
actually help me with my own training
hours uh my observation is that yeah
yeah we have to encourage best practice
we have to encourage professionalism
um so I think this is a generally good
thing I have councilor Parry then
councilor Barker thank you Deputy leader
it's just really a comment
um a number of our counselors work
um training member development training
is best done face to face
but when basically most of the training
sessions are on a specific day at five
o'clock everything every other week it
makes it extremely difficult for people
traveling from the Far East of the
district to get to Elizabeth's house for
five o'clock
when perhaps they don't actually finish
their day job until 5 30 and
joining teams online
still doesn't help because sometimes you
find you you've missed half of it so
what I would ask and that is a plea when
I first became a counselor we had
training sessions that started at six
o'clock not five o'clock and if we are
trying to encourage
um
younger professional people to come on
board as counselors then the training
hours and I know it's a lot of pressure
on officers but there does need to be
say some weeks start at five and other
weeks start at six and not always on the
same day
which is like training day because it
does Clash you know you you might have a
commitment always on a Thursday
um so it's just an observation as
someone who has worked who has found it
extremely difficult an impossibility to
get to here for five o'clock unless
one takes the afternoon off from work
welcome to my world
um councilor Barker and mine
um I agree with what Anna said about the
timings
um I'm also sometimes and I'll be honest
about this concerned about the content
because if you've been around the block
quite a quite a long time it can become
quite dull and you're just being
committed to doing more and more
training on the same thing again and
again and again so I take the option of
doing quite a lot of NHS training which
is
perfectly permissible with my portfolio
but I would encourage other cabinet
members potentially if they've got
access to that kind of thing through
their own that can be quite useful I'm
also concerned about the independence
actually having some training um because
this is all about groups and making sure
that people do things but I think The
Independents need to be encouraged too
I'm conscious that two of The
Independents to my knowledge
I probably find it at the hardest
so
um I suppose if things are if if
training is recorded that would help I I
don't know whether it still is but if
people can then access it to do it once
it's been recorded that may help I I
believe some sessions still are still
available on on record and uh yeah I
mean you make a valid point about and
I'm coming to counselor off next I think
cabinet had it to go you make a valid
point about you can just rock up and you
you've you've got the hours uh I've long
held the view that we should all take an
exam every year improve our competence
actually ask answer some questions but I
I know I'm in a minority of that as for
the conundrum of timing of sessions I'm
sure that member Development Group and
Mr door we will wrestle with that as
they have for many years cancel a role
uh thank you chair uh firstly I think I
need to declare an interest because I
sit on member Development Group and at
the last meeting when these
recommendations were considered and put
forward I wasn't in attendance and I'm
here to tell you that I would never ever
ever ever have agreed to point one
because I think it's an insult to us as
grown-ups
as adults that our leader signs a
commitment
I mean don't you think our leaders have
enough to do but signs of commitment and
keeps an eye on their training hours I
think that's an insult I think we are
perfectly capable
of looking after and I agree with the
last two because I think they're very
interesting because I sit on member
development I do see the owls that
people train
and I think if other people saw it
they'd be more incentivized to turn up
at training sessions in my opinion but I
do think uh that point one should be
erased because I think it's uh the
leaders have enough to do I think uh
councilor Rock has had a kind of vague
conversation with um uh councilor
Jefferson and I think it's a kind of
well you know yeah we've all got a lot
to do and and actually do we want to do
it it is more difficult for The
Independents because there is no if you
like leader but but if you like most of
this is
is for the independent's sake anyway and
it's not for members of the
conservatives and the lib Dems because
most of them have their hours anyway so
I would recommend and I would like you
to agree to that that they take off
point one thank you
councilor Cargill and then I'm going to
come to you cancer Rock councilor
Cargill
thank you very much chair well this is
the as you know I chaired the working
group for a couple of years or a number
of years and I discovered that you're
damned if you do you're damned if you
don't to say we haven't tried
all the options is you know well it's
not right we have tried everything over
the years and I think that we've tried
had a good balance of covid
interestingly forced us down the more
online route which has been quite
beneficial I believe recording of
training sessions has occurred and I
think that's absolutely vital too and
there's many options for people to get
their their hours up on on training and
it is beneficial to just the individual
itself but also to this to the council
so one of the reasons that I totally
disagree with cancer off on this one on
the item one it was there to show a
commitment
now we appreciate that he can't apply to
the
um the independence obviously but there
we hope that they will pick up the the
Baton and say yes we will
um but with the rest of the training
whether I see the councilors and look at
the the second one is that the
spreadsheet with ticket it's it's a
characteristic here isn't it
how else are we going to do this I mean
I'm quite passionate about this I think
that the training system we put forward
is one of the best and it has been for a
long long time we must try and encourage
people we can't do the legal route as as
uh Mr Grafton told us so this is the
only options we have
thank you chair
thank you I've got Castle Rock and did
councilor Crump into case he did indeed
I think thank you chairman
um I I found out I'm in agreement with a
number of things that said particularly
by our Council of powering councilor
Barker
um
taking the first one the group leader
issue
I think
Mr Grafton might put me right but um
you're treating different members
differently
if you deal with the independence
because you can't because there's a
group leader differently to say
Council of Barry or myself where a
leader tells us what to do and I'm not
sure that it's appropriate for somebody
to sign up and and uh cancer off is
quite right I did have a chapter the
leader of the council about this because
I received a number of representations
from my group about it
um
I think it's really difficult I mean I
think uh you know those that work those
that have got professional
qualifications already
that fit in the training round one size
fits all is really tricky having a
numerical count and using that as some
yardstick that says somebody's got you
know I don't know 100 hours over the
year and somebody else has only got 10
doesn't necessarily mean that what we've
done it is particularly suitable
um
I think uh
uh as Council cargo says that the
pandemic and uh remote
we've got a new IV system remote ways of
dealing with things did offer us an
opportunity and I think there were some
benefits in that uh
uh the chief executive and myself I've
discussed how we could expand that I
think one of the problems has been that
uh to record and broadcast the system
requires staff to come in after hours
which is obviously an area of difficulty
perhaps technology is going to help us
there
um so I think that there are some ways
forward so recording and broadcasting
these uh these things do offer us an
opportunity
we can certainly keep spreadsheet we can
keep the non-bus it comes with a health
warning of course perhaps and perhaps
when we publish it that health warning
about the applicability could be put in
uh but I do have reservations has been
expressed by members about the first one
uh and um I I think that's uh worth
thinking about the other thing that's
worth thinking about the the timing and
the consistent timing being every
Thursday night has given me a problem
and it's caused me you know some
personal angst because if I had a fixed
appointment on Thursday nights uh
I do so I have managed to attend a a
reasonable amount of training
finally I would say that we're talking
about this now and The Purge appeared
was mentioned earlier on just remind us
that we're a potent election period and
we'd be making commitments as to what we
do now for
possibly will all be re-elected those
are those of us that might wish to but
new people would come in and uh as
counselor Perry said we would hope we
will get some a cross-section of the
community representing the citizens of
this area which will include possibly
young professionals and all that sort of
thing
thank you very much chairman
councilor Crump and then I have
councilor Harvey
I'm trying to be brief uh to see the uh
Mr chairman lots of things have been
said totally agree with the current
surprise points about people working
people coming from the Far East Etc
um certainly the recording of uh
training sessions is helpful and online
uh just wondered whether members could
attend other councils training sessions
such as the County Council or WC and
highlighted those because Lots
potentially on planning for example
where there's some reciprocal basis
could be done if you weren't able to
attend an SDC one
I think that's something that perhaps
the member Development Group can take
away is there's some kind of portability
around training I we're not going to get
a resolution to that no it's just come
and again I just looked when I first saw
the agenda item on
um incentives to undertake member
training and I was thinking well what
would members of the public think if
counselors had to take
um have incentives to go on training
um when I read the report it was
certainly wasn't that it was
encouragement so perhaps
um the title this this report might have
gone down better with members of the
public if it says encouragement to
undertake members training because some
people wanted to cause Mischief could
say oh look at the characters and I need
incentives to to do training yeah okay
councilor Harvey
not declare an interest I'm a member of
this committee
um I think we should it's this is all
about context I think the number of
errant councilors uh who don't undertake
adequate training however you define
that is very small the vast majority are
responsible and and do
um whatever the words whatever
objections you might have to these words
one suggestion which did not pass
through the committee was that once
you've done your 12 hours counselors
should be given a certificate now if if
you think a resolution number one is
demeaning and unnecessary
um he's got rid of one the final point
I'd like to make is that um
uh
definitely you made the suggestion about
the need for a test
I just point out to everybody that if
you apply to be a polling Clerk or a
presiding officer at an election
you are required to do training and you
are required to do a test and if you
don't pass the test you will not be
employed and I don't see why we should
have double standards
yeah the uh the the the sort of annual
test is a hobby horse of one I'll go to
cancellous
uh I was going to say I've got councilor
shenton and I've got Phil Grafton and
then I think we would probably wrap back
with cancer kettle
thank you Deputy leader um my view on
this is that I have no great issue with
this except that with recommendation one
that each group leader signs a
commitment to ensure their members
achieve the minimum number of training
hours my follow-up my question to that
would be so what
yeah how is that going to be enforced
exactly what cancer Baptist just said
Mr Grafton yeah just on recommendation
one and in reply to Castle Rock's
question of course it is it is your
discretion completely around uh
recommendation one my only comment is in
relation to people who are counselors
who are not members of a political group
um I don't think that prevents
you
um making that recommendation if you
want to okay I understand the point that
they're they're not bound by that but on
the other hand that doesn't mean you
can't
put that forward as a recommendation the
second point is in the report it talks
about
um
where is it now
it talks about it being this is that it
being a recommendation to counsel in the
recommendation itself at the top it
doesn't mention that it it just says
recommendations as if it's the cabinet
that's making this decision so um it
will need it will need to be a
recommendation to counsel in terms of
the I did get the idea that you would
maybe suggesting that any decision taken
there might Fetter discretion later on
of a new counselor I don't think that
would be the case because cancer would
future Council would have a further
opportunity maybe to review this at some
point so I don't think that's a concern
thank you
councilor Kettle and then I think we
need to sort of come to some kind of
resolution here
um
well I've heard I heard the points made
I understand
um
why those points have been made
um this does go as Mr Grafton has just
said this does go to council
um
we could consider some of those as to
whether we do a member working group uh
how some of those coupling implements
are going forward but I would go back it
is really Keen
um as as the chairman says as gifted
amateurs that we keep our
pencils sharp and our Branch sharp and
make sure we represent our
residents or constituents as best as
possible we are only asking the group
leader to commit that their or group
leaders
that their members do partake in
training as best they can
and it is clear that whilst as Council
Harvey has clearly said the majority do
it's not the majority we're concerned
about it's the minority
and therefore one would hope that the um
political process would help
the leaders to focus or the other group
leaders to focus on those members who
aren't doing quite as well as they
should do it's not a binding commitment
on the
um group leader to jump up and down on
with toes it is an encouragement to make
sure that all councilors uh and there is
a problem with the independence because
there isn't a leader that all councilors
are best prepared to help their
constituents and I believe there's
nothing wrong in in ensuring that we do
our utmost to make sure
our members are as best prepared as they
can be okay thank you I mean I think
this is a perennial issue for for this
and other authorities about how we best
ensure there's professionalism in the
way that we operate and um you know
having said that uh you know uh speaking
as somebody who does struggle to to
actually get to do this stuff I think
it's important I'm in the place that
says we should continue to drive
standards
um so broadly uh I'm happy with the
recommendations save perhaps for
substituting the word ensure in
recommendation one to encourage
and let's let cancel come to a view and
that'll be a long debate so I think
we're done to councilor shenton
okay that's that done so with that
change members are we agreed
thank you very much members
we now come to item 8 capital budget
monitoring page 71
um councilor Harvey
thank you Davido the purpose of this
paper is to keep members of the cabinet
informed of the progress made over the
first eight months of the year in
undertaking the council's intended level
of capital expenditure
table two on page 72 demonstrates the
adjusted budgeted intention to undertake
expenditure of 15.3 million pounds this
year including section 106 projects
paragraph 1.4 indicates that capital
expenditure of 6.3 million pounds had
already been undertaken and committed by
the end of November in the first eight
months of the year therefore the sums
spent or committed amount to 42 of this
year's available budget of 15.3 million
appendix 2 on pages 81 to 85 provides
summary information concerning the
various projects yet to be funded
through section 106 agreements of the
grand total of 8.3 million pounds
reported on page 85 some 7.3 million
pounds relates to funds identified for
the provision of affordable housing I
ask therefore Deputy leader that the
recommendation set out on page 71 of the
report in relation to the eight months
period to the end of November 2022 be
received
thank you councilor Harvey I am I am
minded to recall a remarkoft made by a
member of this Authority uh
um who who sort of stepped down some
years ago it is what it is based on it
is what it is
um anybody any particular observations
councilor Rock any observations if not
we move to note the No No chairman I
think it you were right it is what it is
thank you I was I knew you were there I
knew you were there
with that I don't think that I'm not
seeing anybody wanting to indicate let's
move to item nine Revenue budget
monitoring
agreed we agreed
no capital budget monitoring are we
agreed agreed we're now moving to
capital budget monitoring page 87 of
your papers councilor Harvey Revenue
budgeting monetary
thank you deaf leader
the purpose of this report is to inform
the cabinet of the revenue picture of
the council's finances to the end of
November 2022. I'd like to begin by
asking members to turn to appendix 3 on
page 99.
this shows that the net budget to be
financed by the council this year is
18.2 million pounds
if we now turn to appendix 2 on page 97
we can see that the budget for the whole
year is for the total expenditure of
34.5 million pounds and the total income
from various sources of 18.2 million
pounds the difference between these two
numbers in round terms 16.3 million
pounds together with the net cost of the
total of the cost of benefits of 232 000
pounds represents the total amount to be
funded from various sources in other
words 16.6 million pounds as set out in
appendix 2.
turning to the position of the period of
end of period eight we can see from
appendix 2 that in round terms the
council's expenditure of 21.4 million
pounds was 1.9 million pounds more than
budgeted this reflects a variety of
reasons set out in Section 3 both
positive and negative in relation to
each head of service
a combination of these results means
that the net cost of services provided
in the first eight months of the year
excluding the net cost of benefits of
387
000 pounds was 9.1 billion pounds 801
000 pounds less than it had been
budgeted sections three and five of the
paper identify the principal items of
variance from their budgeted figures
During the period of April to November
due to a contribution of both favorable
and unfavorable Reasons by the service
category and by the type of income and
expenditure
section 4 however provides a projection
of the likely outturn for the year as a
whole based on results to date and
projections informed by current
information and estimates based on the
experience of heads of service
the outturn for the year as a whole is
shown in appendix one and is anticipated
to be favorable outturn of 998
000 pounds
section 6 of the paper demonstrates that
on the basis of present expectations for
the current year and in contrast to the
position reported in October 2022 when
the council's reserve position at the
end of 22-23 was anticipated that the
level of reserves would be reduced by
eight hundred thousand pounds
it's now anticipated that the general
Reserve account will increase from 8.5
million pounds to 10.3 million pounds in
addition the council's current earmarked
reserves stand at 11.7 million pounds as
identified in appendix 4.
before concluding I'd like to draw
attention within appendix one to the two
largest variations against budget to the
end of November first the outcome in
relation to the net cost of housing
benefits where to the end of November
there was a negative variance of 270 000
pounds
this is anticipated to grow to a
negative variance of 350 000 pounds by
the end of the financial year this is a
net cost over which by its nature the
council has little control
on the other hand interest generated on
the council's fund balances was 609 000
pounds ahead of budget by the end of
November as and is anticipated to be 1.3
million pounds ahead of budget by the
end of March
in some measure this is attributable to
the skill of the council's fund managers
in large measure however it's
attributable to the market consequences
of the decisions of the monetary policy
Committee of the bank of England over
base rate decisions
these countervailing results and our
judgments based upon them have provided
the basis for what is proposed under the
following item the cap the revenue and
capital budget for 23.24
unless there are any points of
information Mr Burrell might wish to
provide or any questions from Members I
asked the report be received
thank you very much councilor Harvey any
observations or from members of cabinets
if not a councilor Kettle and then I'll
come to counselor Rock cancel the kettle
um
I'll get rid of my crib sheet
um
the budgets this Council actually
approved was
18.703 Million
and that was the figure that was signed
off in our February
for council meeting
um I think it would be helpful for
everybody to understand in future
we have on appendix 3 the net budget for
22.23 as a first of April is 18.19
million now that is a significant
difference
um and I think if for people reading
these papers would have seen that the
budget was agreed at 18.7 that we
understand the full movement from that
18.7 to the 16.6 to which counts the
Harvey referred to earlier on
it's a matter of explanation and not a
question as to what the figures are but
I think before going forward we need to
start off with a figure that this
Council approved in this chamber
thank you Mr Burrell can you bring some
clarity please yes okay the 18.7 does
include an amount for climate change and
the Jubilee celebrations so that
amounted to 510 000 pounds
um that is those two items are with now
within the amount Reserve so not part of
the revenue account that's monitored so
the difference between the 18.1 and the
18.7 is that 510 000.
I I understand that but it doesn't say
that in the report and therefore I think
we need to see this clarification that
if we're moving items out of income and
expenditure into reserves then clearly
climate change we understand why that is
happening but there may be other items
that are moving as well in the future
which we are unable to understand so
that's my first point but thank you for
that explanation the second point is the
recharges to other accounts
uh now I've raised this before now
recharges to other accounts is actually
movements between income and expenditure
and uh ear markers earmarked and other
Reserves
um now some of that earmarked and other
reserves uh movement is real expenditure
where this Council has spent money
paying invoices or paying fees or paying
whatever it may be
but some of that
um amount of money is actually where
reserves have been released because
they're not necessarily seen to be
required going forward and therefore not
real money leaving this council's
coffers
um it would definitely be really helpful
I think if we're going to go forward
with this that we actually have again an
explanation of where we have spent money
at reserves and where we have not
because we've released money that's
actually not spending it it's just
actually
um
saying we don't we don't anticipate in
the future we're going to need to do so
um I'm trying to put that into simple
terms Mr chairman as possible I also
know councilor Kettle you've failed
miserably but then I don't understand
excel
in the the figure in the rechargeable
reserves is 971
um and in appendix 4 we do have those
two figures
um
making up that movement and it it
doesn't come up to the it comes up to
different figure
so I think again we need to have real
clarify well I mean you refer you refer
in your report I think uh if Mr Burrell
can you comment or if there is a
question that you need to take offline
around some of the maths then can you
take that offline and then provide a a
round robin to Cabinet if you've got to
be checking anything if there is a
because I can see you've got your
calculator there
I have just I make it one one pound
difference but I just think that's
rounding to be honest uh German okay but
I think yes it's in in page 92 the third
bullet point I think the figure
referring to is nine five seven and the
figure in the in in the chancellor
Kettle I think the chief exec would like
to to come in and probably help help
give some further Clarity no Joe I was
just requesting that we should be
allowed footage is is explanation thank
you
yeah some of the some of the amounts are
released to um the majority of the
amounts are released to cover
expenditure that is contained within the
revenue account so money is held to one
side in an earmark Reserve expenditure
is done through Supply services or
employee costs in the revenue account
and that money's drawn in under that
heading as you say to me that but the
the appendix four or the two items added
together like I said it's within a pain
and I do think that's just rounding
well sorry in 92 you say the figure is
957 not 971.
foreign
the variance is nine seven one
this has got the feel of something that
just needs to be looked at because I
think I can see yeah it's flicking
between I think we're not going to
resolve this but I think there's a
there's there's something if there if
there is some
demonstrable or significant change can
you arrange to provide a circle an
update cancer Kettle details but I think
if between the two you take it offline
and if there's something if there's
something then to update cabinet further
that would be good
um thank you one last point
and it will be the last it will be
absolutely the outturn
um 988 is to be welcomed
um
and actually as we know the year-to-date
figures five three one the outturn for
the remaining four months is to improve
that by four six seven but the vast
majority of that is the interest
um and what we see is actually the 192
which 192 000 which is the
um positive clearance to date excluding
housing benefit and interest
reverts reverses to a uh 144 000 deficit
in the remaining four months
I just wonder why we're going for a
positive variance in the first eight
months to a negative variance in the
last four
Mr burrow
to be honest kind of scared I'll don't
entirely follow what you said because we
shall share it with you after the
meeting yeah okay
on that appendix yeah one it goes from a
period eight positive variance of five
three one two an out turn of 998.
I think I'll take it offline and can we
take it off can I make a general
observation and I speak as one of the
non-accountants in this room
um you know you could have been talking
I'm gonna be talking French to me
um I think that there are some it's
really good and there are some really
detailed questions I think where it is
practicably possible and I appreciate
that's not always the case and I'm I'm
saying this for all cabinet members if
you know particularly with the finances
if we've got something you know some
some some technical questions I think it
might be where possible useful to give a
heads up so that then the officers can
prepare because that then gives the rest
of cabinets particularly those of us who
don't speak numbers the opportunity to
understand what's just gone on for the
last five minutes
might have suggest going back to the
previous item on the agenda uh that we
could have a training course for finance
for non-financial experts
that is not every single one of them
that is not part of the member
development working group and I will I
will ensure that it never it
but no I think these are these are these
are these are valid questions and they
are questions we need to understand you
know we need to understand the numbers
you know even I need to understand the
numbers but I think sometimes I think if
we can give the officers the opportunity
to have had that thinking space to come
back so that we get you know we get
really detailed understandable answers
councilor Rock
uh thank you chairman and uh I would
refer members to my previous answer from
the previous item it is what it is
notwithstanding their very interesting
debate and I would say speaking as a
chartered engineer that went on a course
that said uh Finance for non-financial
officers
It Ain't Easy
Mr chairman can I just councilor Harvey
you may indeed
um I think the last five minutes has has
demonstrated that when a counselor and
an officer have a bilateral conversation
amongst themselves which does not
involve other counselors it shows that
there is something not quite right the
obligation that we have is to Monitor
and that monitoring should be done by
all councilors and the conversation
should be one which is inclusive of all
counselors if there are technical issues
to be discussed which may have the
veracity but this is not the place for
that discussion
I I
I'm going to bring the item to a close
Okay in the sense that we have a report
to to be noted I think there is an
opportunity to uh seek some clarity and
for cabinet to be brought to up to speed
on any issue that is of relevance around
the numbers
um so with that I'm now going to move us
to the next item of the agenda which is
item uh sorry thank you so much
you'll be much better at this than I am
um are we all agreed with the noting of
the report receiving of the report
agree can I just make sure that we
understand that there is a second part
which is the write-off of several small
items yes
item 10 on the agenda
on page 103 of your papers the revenue
and capital budget 2324 consultation of
scrutiny and
ah Kel surprise counselor Harvey
thank you Deputy leader
the purpose of this paper is to present
the draft revenue and capital budgets
for 23.24 and succeeding years to the
cabinet for endorsement as the basis
upon which both the public and the
overview and scrutiny committee can be
consulted that is the purpose of this
paper
the intention is that the outcome of
these consultations will be considered
by their cabinet at its meeting on the
13th of February before the final
proposals are then put before the
council at its meeting on the 27th of
February
as all members of the cabinet will be
aware the proposals set out in the paper
are the result of detailed discussions
over a series of meetings between
members of the management team and
individual portfolio holders where
agreement was reached on spending
proposals that have been put forward
the result is that a balanced budget as
required of all local authorities by
legislation is set out in the papers
members will notice that the scale of
the anticipated Surplus this year is
similar to the proposed budgeted deficit
for next year and will be financed from
Reserves the proposed budget is based on
what are regarded as reasonable
assumptions given the vagaries of the
art of seeing into the future
arguably the most significant assumption
is the rate of inflation incorporated
into the budget as set out in paragraph
3.2
there is no certainty about these
assumptions being fulfilled they have
been made however having had regard to
the Authority's cost structure and the
contractual Financial Obligations it has
entered into
it also needs to be born in mind that
these assumptions uh sorry I'll start
that again it also needs to be born in
mind that were these assumptions to
prove to be unduly optimistic interest
rates would also be higher for longer
than has been assumed generating
additional interest earnings members of
the cabinet can therefore take some
comfort that there is an underlying
resilience in the assumptions on which
the budget is presented for consultation
the budget is based on the premise that
given existing funding Arrangements the
council's existing range of services
will continue to be provided section 3.9
of the paper however sets out the ways
in which the budget proposes some
marginal increases in expenditure in
order to provide and develop improved
services in areas such as environmental
health and planning the provision of
self-build and custom-built housing
further support in the areas of energy
and financial advice and the creation of
apprenticeship to develop the council's
legal services
we are all well aware of the impact of
the current rate of inflation
particularly of energy and food prices
is having on household budgets generally
and particularly on those in the
district with the lowest incomes and or
exceptional needs
with this in mind the projected outcome
of the council's finances for The
Current financial year has benefited
from the higher than anticipated
interest rates on the return on balances
held over the past year this together
with the terms of the government's draft
settlement announced on the 19th of
December has enabled the inclusion in
the budget of a cost of living support
fund to which 250 000 pounds will be
allocated for next year and a further
250 000 pounds earmarked for the
following year
whilst a district council cannot address
every individual need due to the rate of
inflation
investigations are underway on how this
fund might be allocated within the
district to best affect where it can
make the greatest impact for as many
residents with understandable needs as
possible
it would not be prudent to base the
council's finances on further
unanticipated earnings from its funds
given the vagaries of financial markets
and the absence of the council's
influence or control over future
interest rates and pay settlements
this year's pay settlement was a flat
sum of
1925 25 pounds per employee
in Stratford's case this was the
equivalent of an additional of some six
percent to the council's salary costs
there is the prospect that next year's
pay settlement could be of a similar
order of magnitude
it's against this background that it's
proposed to increase next year's council
tax on a ban D property by five pounds
that is from 154 pounds twelve to 159
pounds 12. this is the equivalent of an
increase of just 3.2 percent on this
year's level and is significantly lower
than either the current
or the projected rate of inflation for
next year
Stratford District council's precept is
currently the 19th lowest amongst the
countries 181 District councils
despite this proposed increase Stratford
will remain one of the country's
district councils with the lowest
council tax rate
before concluding Deputy leader I'd like
to place on record my thanks for the
Sterling work that has been undertaken
by our offices in putting these budget
proposals together in particular I'd
like to thank Richard Burrell our
section 151 officer and his staff for
the diligence and stamina they have
displayed over recent months and to all
heads of service who played their
creative Parts in drafting their budget
proposals based on their experience and
their foresight all Drawn Together of
course by David Buckland our chief
executive
finally but not least I'd like to thank
members of the cabinet for their
contributions to the debates and the
discussions that have culminated in
these budget proposals this really has
been a team effort I ask there for
members of the cabinet to approve
recommendations one to eight set out on
page 103 of the paper as the basis for
the council's consultation with the
relevant interested parties in the
council's revenue and capital budget
2023-2024 set out in the paper and its
Associated appendices
thank you David
thank you councilor Harvey the
recommendation is that the uh the in
essence the revenue and capital budget
is endorsed and recommended for scrutiny
um any members of cabinet any
observations or comments to make and
then undoubtedly councilor Rock will
wish to have a quick observation
nope cast The Rock the floor is yours
thank you wait until it opens up beneath
you
thank you you haven't got this trap ball
you talked about earlier on but um uh
first of all I'd like to uh endorse uh
What uh councilor Harvey said about
thanking the officers for their diligent
work in preparing these figures which
um
I wouldn't dream to
try and pick up on individual points
however I'm just going to do that now is
it with a question
um on page one two one
uh
uh there is a new homes bonus slash
three percent funding guarantee
written in the same line
now I'm not completely okay with this
but I understand these are quite
separate issues because the government's
just come up with a three percent
funding guarantee
should that not be shown in a separate
line to Aid counselors in their
deliberations
otherwise that's that's my only question
chance
Mr Burrell
thank you the chairman yes it could
um it would just add another line it was
my choice to show it in in a single line
the new homes bonuses coming to an end
the government's confirmed all the
Legacy payments from previous years
has ceased so indeed the the amount
that's been
communicated for 20 23 24 four new homes
bonuses is 1.9 million
um the there is a completely different
funding guarantee three percent funding
guarantee something completely different
from new homes bonus that has been
introduced this year
whether that continues or not we don't
know
um so you know I could have put three
lines in there one for new homes bonus
one for three percent funding guarantee
for one year then something else for the
future years Beyond 23 24 so yeah I've
rolled it into one it's the splits
Twitter 1.9 and 2.2 for the three
percent funding guarantee and going
forward
they've not said what they'll be
replacing either of those with
thank you Mr Burrell so I think in
essence the section one five off one
officer has chosen to put this in a in a
single line that seems a rational
explanation to me again uh I'm not a
numbers man
um and undoubtedly
um when the further scrutiny uh
processes uh run through I'm sure that
explanation will be made available to
those scrutinizing the budget and to to
members when we come to the uh the
budget debate further down the track
I think with that unless there's any
other observation the recommendation is
that items one through eight on page 103
be endorsed and recommended for scrutiny
um are we all agreed
agreed thank you very much members I
come now to part C issues arising from
overview and scrutiny committee uh
councilor crumpers or anything I don't
have anything noted in these papers but
is there anything briefly yeah I'll be
very brief first of all yes the task
unfinished group uh from your vision
excuse me we'll be looking at the budget
and there's a meeting on Wednesday
um secondly at the osc on Friday we
discussed the shared intelligence report
on on the merger Lessons Learned review
um the report was discussed and accepted
as a meaningful worthwhile exercise and
there's been there was active
participation by WDC and SCC officers
and members which ensured a quality
report was produced
the report has already gained traction
nationally with an article in the
municipal Journal and the LGA which part
of the report uh was provided amongst
its members and the report is likely to
be going to cabinet for endorsement
rather than the council as it relates to
the executive functions as I was told by
Mr Perks on Friday so if that's wrong
blame Mr Perks
um
there was a um a session from the
portfolio of the holder for planning and
I think one of the things that came out
that
members did need more understanding
about the planning process enforcement
development and building control and the
portfolio holders currently agreed to do
a not so brief breathing note
and finally the housing strategy action
plan
um that was on the agenda was due to was
deferred to February's meeting due to
length in conflicts debate discussion on
the previous items and it was well
attended by both the leader and the
chief executive
um so yeah a great meeting thank you
thank you very much councilor Crump uh
Part D cabinet committees uh no papers
for that part e on block items I've not
been advised before the start of the
meeting for any item to be discussed so
on block we take items 11 cabinet work
program item 12 member development
working group and item 13
stratford-upon-avon Market Forum on
block
Part F of the matters urgent business
I've not been advised of any urgent
business and with that being the case I
declare the meeting closed thank you